c'est le pire score de l'histoire pour
les césar et pour nous faire un kiff
on voudrait voir là pour voir la
première décès là c'est en 76 qui a eu
la toute première cérémonie des césar à
l'époque c'est jean gabin qui a été le
président quelques mois avant sa mort et
pierre tchernia était le maître de
cérémonie
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir c'est le cinéma qui nous réunit
ce soir est le but de cette
manifestation est d'honorer la
profession cinématographique tout
entière vous le savez les rapports entre
le cinéma et la télévision était souvent
tumultueux difficile en termes de a été
la première des sociétés de programmes a
signé un armistice avec le cinéma il y a
un an
et justement antenne 2 est heureux de
penser que ce soir il s'agit d'une fête
de famille qui réunit le cinéma et la
télévision
alors la première des césar merci eric
naulleau d'être là c'est vrai que vous
avez été très virulent sur twitter
concernant la cérémonie des search et
que j'adorais le cinéma est donc
forcément quand on aime le cinéma c'est
vraiment les saisir
non mais c'était compliqué las les césar
alors en 46 cérémonie des césars ont
connu une vingtaine de présentateurs
différent à chaque fois évidemment
chaque maître de cérémonie a voulu
amener son style sa petite panne
d'antoine de caunes à florence foresti
edouard baer jérôme commandeur se sont
tous donnés à fond regarder petit récap
et on va revoir
bien sûr tout de suite après la
prestation de marina foïs c'est parti
couché avec un réalisateur de courts
métrages
c'est un plaisir mais c'est aussi un
formidable pari sur l'avenir
du coup
[Applaudissements]
pour remettre le césar du meilleur film
étranger
j'appelle florian philippot non c'est
juste pour vous réveiller un césar c'est
pas tous les jours qu'on reçoit et et
surtout on en a pas tous les citer tous
les jours bien d'accord
à part peut-être jacques audiard qui
peut jouer au cap là avec ses armes par
benoît z conserver dame est ainsi il en
est à mon sens monsieur tête ils ont un
bracelet électronique
bon réécoutez bienvenus
[Musique]
les chiens forestier laisse toujours
très nul 4-4 son chien alors les cheese
les shihri césar 2021 et s la cérémonie
la plus éclatée de l'histoire vendredi
soir c'était la 46e cérémonie des césar
sur canal+ le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que cette cérémonie a fait
énormément parler entre audiences
catastrophiques intervention gênante
acting pape en particulier discours
politique la cérémonie a été une des
moins regardée de l'histoire mais une
des plus commentés moelleux juste un
truc à dire c'est quand même que le
plateau était très bon produit non voilà
le bateau était très beau l'orchestré
des gabarres et c'était très bon voilà
côté cabarry montrent les plus patrick
sébastien et ça aurait été parfait mais
a malheureusement il s'est passé que
sébastien la présentation petit
récapitulatif et dites-nous chez vous
même ceux qui n'ont pas vu regarder avec
serez capable de nous faire une idée de
ce qu'on a vu eric naulleau pour vous
comme ça à priori c'était la pire ah oui
je ne mets de très loin de très loin le
monde s'y met
et le césar de la cérémonie la plus
gênante et d'attribuer aux césars 2021
jeudi soir avait lieu la 46e cérémonie
des césar et on peut dire que c'était
l'une des pires cérémonie de l'histoire
je sais très embarrassé bah oui était
très embarrassée dalhem aussi je suis
très embarrassé n'y a pas que ton entre
discours politiques ou trop versé sketch
qui tombent à plat et malaise en tous
genres alors coquine
c'est qu'il est nommé pour le meilleur
film de cul de hockey documentaire on
sait que le confinement a fait beaucoup
de mal au cinéma la cérémonie de cette
année avait beaucoup de mal aux
téléspectateurs cette année ils étaient
que 1,6 million à célébrer la victoire
du fils d'albert dupontel et c'est cette
récompense
quant à moi il ne me reste plus qu'à
vous dire adieu les comptes et à l'année
prochaine
les chevilles alors c'est vrai que c'est
une des pires d'audience ces dernières
années c'est la pire audience et en part
de marché 9,1 c'est la pire audience
depuis plus de dix ans on a dû remonter
après dix ans et même on n'a pas trouvé
sachez le voilà déjà première question
c'est marina fort hills à la
présentation
marina foïs voilà qui faisait partie
avant des robins des bois est-ce que
c'était une mauvaise idée de mettre
marina foïs à la présentation voulait
voir une compile de l'avant ou pas allez
petit coupé
les chiens forestier laisse toujours
très 1400 cher ça tue les vieux et les
gros mais comme on dit en afrique c'est
quoi un gros merci mademoiselle merci
veuillez vous bien vous barrez j'imagine
que tout ça va encore me retomber sur la
schneck vous deviez dire une petite [ __ ]
c'est pas grave si les cuisson rosée
quelle claque bien contre les faits ça
compense j'avais fort marina mais c'est
qui qui disent ah ah bah tout le monde à
part des simpson enfin quelqu'un de bien
et nous mêmes donc c'est génial j'adore
alors il ya eu peur d'articles à
regarder le figaro nombriliste vulgaire
politiser la cérémonie des césars la
plus calamiteuse de l'histoire césar
2021 au secours n'en jetez plus voilà
peu de public dans la salle et devant la
télévision cérémonie des césar il y
avait le titanic aussi ils ont dit voilà
le titanic est de retour c'est un
article magnifique du figaro alors
marina foïs une mauvaise idée pour vous
celle vers détruits elle n'a pas le
talent elle n'a aucun charisme elle
n'avait pas de texte c'est un naufrage
je ne comprends même pas comment
quelqu'un a pu avoir l'idée de la mettre
là parce que tout était écrit elle n'a
pas l'envergure pour ça c'est un mauvais
choix et je les trouvais figé tétanisé
gênante c'est une catastrophe bien vous
en faites
on sent que dès le début elle est pas à
l'aise avec les textes avec les sketches
pour info les textes et blanche gardin
qui est une excellente humoriste qui les
aide mais laurent l'a coécrit avec
laurent lafitte méchant que ça sonnait
comme du blanche gardin et dans la
bouche de l'ange-gardien je trouve ça
aurait été plus drôle on sent qu'elle
n'était pas à l'aise avec ses textes
sont selon moi c'est ça le problème
il mettra blanche gardin elle articule
un eric naulleau mais moi je vais pas
distinguer une personne plus qu'une
autre c'était un naufrage collectif
rien n'allait rien n'allait en plus ce
qui a été dit l'apapar verdez sais que
c'est pas un dérapage dans cette
émission elle a été pensée si j'ose dire
elle a été préméditée elle a été répétée
donc ces gens là voulait donner cette
image du cinéma français à venir ils
sont complètement détachée de toute
réalité dieu je veux dire un truc
les producteurs n'étaient pas au courant
du tout des textes ou voilà et notamment
des happenings tout ça non je vous le
dis voilà donc il a devancé libre oui
mais c'est c'est comme ça ils ont laissé
libraire liberté d'expression d'artiste
mais je trouve que c'est un parti pris
et bravo à eux parce que ils ont fait je
trouve leur travail jeudi 66 et des
potes
bonjour je dis c'est demain que les deux
producteurs ont là je le dis et vous
avez vu on dit ce qu'on pense de la
cérémonie mais artistiquement je trouve
que le plateau était très bon mais bon
on ne sait pas d'accord avec vous aussi
allez vous avez droit c'est censé donner
une certaine image du cinéma je suis pas
pour la censure mais je suis quand même
pour la re lecture
moi j'aurais été producteur je tombe sur
cette aide je leur dis ça ne va pas vous
refaites tout vous donner une image
catastrophique du cinéma français vous
savez il ya plein de gens j'ai dit sur
les réseaux j'ai changé mes amis je leur
ai dit ne vous laissez pas tromper par
la cérémonie les films récompensés sont
plutôt des bons free c'est vrai les gens
ne répond je n'irai plus exactement voir
un film français parce que je ne veux
plus donner d'argent à ces gens là
d'abord on assure marina foïs bonne idée
ou pas il appelle moi je trouve que
vraiment c'est l'une des plus mauvaises
idées qu'on n'ait jamais eu d'abord
parce que pardonnez moi pour présenter
la soirée
il faut quand même articulé avoir un
minimum de présence et pardonnez-moi
marina foïs n'avait pas de présence je
trouve
vendredi soir sur canal elle était comme
ça et puis même si on n'est pas pour le
glamour ya quand même un minimum vital
en présentation quand on est la
présentatrice de toute la soirée qui
supposait on aurait là dedans la soirée
en plus isolé non récompensés et
confiance et en plus un seul un déficit
de glamour du fait du virus or elle
accentue cette impression de tristesse
mais absolue je suis désolé moi c'était
une première déception quant à démineurs
ertaines elle était très belle vente des
biens son truc
quand j'ai vu le à l'image aussi mais
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible un
tel naufrage avant même qu'elle ouvre la
bouche yacine qui nous a rejoints pour
le débris des césar bon déjà je suis
content que je suis content d'être là
pour dans l'apaisement mais je trouve
déjà que la cérémonie est trop longue
et quand c'est pas drôle excellons
puisque par exemple si un spectacle
n'est pas drôle ça dure une heure mais
là sur tout ce qui est dur je pense pour
marina comme pour je parle aussi pour de
mes collègues humoristes c'est un peu
notre rêve à tous d'animer les césar il
en fait il ya deux il ya deux moments
dans la vie des césar s'est déjà souvent
on a copié les oscars avec moins de
moyens et c'était risible et maintenant
il ya ce truc de dire faire rentrer son
univers dans les césar c'est la pire des
idées parce que les césars comme
zeynioglu chasse est d'accord ça doit
rester un truc tellement glamour c'est
la vitrine un peu darty de du cinéma
français qui doit donner envie d'aller
voir des films
alors malheureusement quand ça marche
pas dès le début après un des moments
les plus marquants de la cérémonie nous
a été offert par corinne nasiru la
comédienne culte de capitaine marleau
voulaient dénoncer la façon dont le
gouvernement traite le monde de la
culture est elle s'est adressée
directement au premier ministre jean
castex
sachez que la production ne savait pas
qu'elle allait faire sa corrida 0 elle
leur a dit je veux faire un sketch show
sur peau d'âne et après bien sûr ils ont
vu qu'ils étaient arrivés alors corinne
mazine loisirs ou coup de génie ou qudra
sera au coude en bois regardez c'est
parti c'est quoi ces colonnes j'aime et
le césar du meilleur costume peau d'âne
c'est bien alors gérer notre costume si
tu veux si je suis peut être les ports
c'est plus cinéphiles à c'est carrie au
bal du diable ça va c'est trop trash
aussi bages et le dernier a pris de ne
plus un dernier c'est qui veut la peau
de roger la thermite aura maintenant on
est comme savent tout mais voilà est
sous l'eau
alors vous voulez tout de génie n'a dit
on pose la question aux téléspectateurs
ont déjà fausse note quand même dans le
contexte dans lequel nous sommes nous
artistes et du monde du cinéma c'est
qu'on est dans une situation extrêmement
difficile et je pense que de toute façon
je reviens juste pardon assure marina
foïs pardon parce que je trouvais que
vous aviez été particulièrement on est
vraiment non du fait qu'elle fait
actuellement factuel en fait on est dans
un moment de toute façon où c'était
compliqué de présenter les césars faut
premièrement j'étais extrêmement contre
il est malheureux que c est trop dur à
ses partenaires ou la prise en charge
est pas fini isabelle est pour moi le
césar de la route c'était l'année
dernière avec polanski mais je voulais
juste vous dire le moment politique que
vient de de nous donner corps et de
mazères aucune actrice engagée la dose
quelques temps ordinaire qu'est et
c'était un moment très très fort et de
tout temps les artistes se sont engagés
politiquement
on a eu des coluche on a eu emmanuelle
béart et c'était vraiment très très fort
que corinne masiero nous sommes ce
moment politique moi ça m'a vraiment
fait du bien et qu'elle était soulevée
avant il fallait animer les césars
maintenant il va falloir les réanimer
après cette prestation après ce n'est
pas la même chose non mais alors si vous
désirez aller sera jamais pire mathiron
c'est ce que je lui reproche c'est pas
d'avoir montré ses fesses c'est qu'elle
est elle prétend représenter les plus
faibles d'entre nous les plus fragiles
ce qu'on appelle c'est pas une
expression très heureuse mais la france
d'en bas et elle pense que la france
d'en bas elle doit être présentée par la
vulgarité
alors que la france d'en bas elle a
droit à la dignité se mettre nu est ce
que c'est vulgaire là de la manière dont
elle l'a fait avec les tampons
hygiéniques autour des oreilles voilà je
trouve d'une vulgarité sans nom ensuite
je pense pas que la france d'en bas où
les gens qu'elle prétend représenter
fasse des fautes d'orthographe comme
elle
héritée du spectacle le plus grand de
vraiment quand on veut représenter les
plus faibles on essaie de rester digne
car ils ont droit à la dignité son droit
à un autre spectacle que celui qui a
offert ma 0 et gilles verdez des coups
de semonce s'agit pas du tout d'accord
avec eric naulleau parce que pour moi
c'est un coup de génie pour deux raisons
c'est la seule qui ait pensé aux gens
dans cette cérémonie si cas où il était
nombriliste enfin elle elle pense aux
intermittents aux gens qui luttent et
elle le dit aline tout le nombril
deuxième et deuxièmement réseau mettre
nue c'est un courage absolue cm mais
pour moi il porte son courage elle dit
je me fous de tout je sais qu'en soins
et cures et non moi j'admire sa eric
franchement j'admire son geste
géraldine non mais elle a des couilles
mal a des couilles pourquoi en fait elle
elle combat quoi elle montrera et
d'énergie elle remettait elle remettait
le césar du meilleur costume gagné le
césar
voilà mais je vois là mais bien son nom
mais d'ailleurs d'ailleurs je vous dis
c'est madame fontaine pour la bonne
épouse qui a fait un travail
extraordinaire
alors qu elle n en a rien à [ __ ] de la
donne son nom mais ce numéro c'est un
numéro moi je trouve pourquoi pas sorte
de cabaret politique pourquoi pas mais à
ce moment là c'est pas les césar mais en
tant que téléspectatrice j'ai envie
qu'on parle de cinéma de larmes
d'émotion et de panache
j'ai envie d'aller voir ce film que je
n'ai pas pu voir alors avant le
confinement voilà mais j'ai pas envie si
tu veux je trouve moi nadège qu elle l a
pris en otage le plateau pour en faire
une sorte de tribune politique était
complètement suivi dont géraldine mais
le monde du cinéma en ce moment ça des
gens qui ne travaillent pas à temps
qu'il avait dans la tête et je sais que
nous ne sommes pas les seuls alors c'est
pas la fonction des résultats nous ne
sommes pas les seuls mais c'est vraiment
important à 200 parle aussi de
questionner les questions politiques
c'est pour parler aux plus grands noms
mais l'addition d'une grande précarité
réalisation est très très difficile je
le sais pour tout le monde et pour les
gens du film il ya malgré tout deux sont
films qui ont été produits en 2020 sa
tournée d'adieux attention grâce à
l'exception ajoute laurence m on finance
quand même l'exception culturelle
française à coup de renfort et de
renforts et des millions 1,2 milliard
d'euros ont été injectés alors il ya des
gens qui disaient pas rien s'il ya des
gens qui disent coup de génie la preuve
elle a réussi son coup et on en parle et
c'est ce qu'elle voulait voilà
les gatinois qu'elles causent la terre
milan qui s'est passé depuis cette
séquence est ce que les choses
combien on a cité son nom et le nom de
la lauréate
combien de fois un pour 1 million
stéphane tapis moi j'adore le cinéma et
du début décidé cette cérémonie jusqu'à
la fin je me suis emmerdé haut possible
c'était pas drôle c'était si tu dis que
les producteurs n'étaient pas au courant
de l'art bdd des sketches qui elle est
ni ben pardon c'est une faute
professionnelle nord-isérois entière
casquette fait pas sens après celui
boulette oudéa vérité c'est très
compliqué de parler je vous le dis eh
ben on n'apprenait pas oui mais moi je
vous le dit les échos que j'ai c'est
compliqué lui dire ça c'est pas drôle ça
c'est drôle mais aller à l'essai mais
les salariés
ah oui mais bon c'est compliqué mais là
le truc du bureau toile de caunes ouais
je trouve que tout on essaye de faire
son show le show de ces la cepal a fait
du cinéma pour ça que c'est la frette de
du duel entre cette cérémonie entre soi
et pour moi c'est cette merde quand
j'aime le cinéma j'ai pas envie de voir
cette espèce de laideron avec ça
d'accord avec toi et ça c'est pas
dégueulasse que passé mais de versailles
a manifesté ses montées en quoi ceci
avait négocié mais vous juger par son
physique madame et je sais que sony je
parle dans la folie général à l'arrivée
chacun dans leur magnifique rappelle
l'histoire d'un homme c'est ce n'est pas
vous savez c'est ce qu'a l'a dit on l'a
vu elle a dit en fait que ce qu'on lui
reproche c'est justement dot d'avoir un
certain âge et de ne pas faire 1,36
alors si c'est ça qui vous dérange c'est
à dire que si vous avez vu une femme
plus mince et qui nous semble la plus
belle excusez moi je vous avais dû
l'annoncer logiciel finir non mais moi
excusez moi je moi ce qui me choque
c'est que par exemple que enlevé enlever
votre action vous plaît ma chérie parce
qu'on perd 6 qui me choque c'est que
dominique boutonnat président du cnc
soit mis en examen pour violences
sexuelles et soient encore en charge du
cnc et ne démissionne pas ça pour moi
c'est vulgaire mais c'est mal fait qu'on
peut pas dire ça sur corinne majek
naulleau mois dans cette cérémonie je
n'ai vu que des gens qui essayait de
tirer la couverture à eux voilà marina
foïs a déjà été nommée cinq fois je les
ai pas eus même si c'est de l'ironie je
trouve que c'est déplacé ce café naz 0
c'est vouloir qu'on retienne de cette
cérémonie
ce qu'elle a fait son petit à la
réussite à la réussite mais les métaux
que le cinéma français est ce que c'est
une cérémonie au service des gens qui
sont sur la salle 1 ou au service du
cinéma c'est en général
moi j'ai vues d'amérique et vient
traduire sa suggestion de petits numéros
y goûte situe pose aussi la question de
du cinéma en vis-à-vis des français
moi par exemple un film que je respecte
pour son succès c'est les tuche je
trouve ça anormal comme j'ai trouvé ça
anormal de traitement complet
dilicom jugnot le lendemain dit sur rtl
qu on les a un peu cachée et moi ce que
je n'aime pas c'est aussi dans cet
humour blanche et la edith piaf de
l'humour c'est un génie et je suis
d'accord sion constat c'est mieux dans
sa bouche que dans la bouche des autres
mais vraiment l'idée peut-être même de
réfléchir à l'arrêt des geysers pour
l'hérault pour un message avec une
formule plus et on vient c'est le
concerne j'aimerais qu'on met sur
corinne masiero s'il vous plaît quand il
m'a dit oh ou des mails aux coudres à
train et c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de
gens qui sont indignés parce que vous
avez dissimulé non mais c'est dans mes
stéphane c'est vrai pardon mais elle est
pleine de change relève et on pousse sur
les oreilles c'est isabelle mon rival
merengue c'est le moment d'en parler au
ces mais en fait c'est une manière de
dénoncer il avait le moment dans lequel
elle n'a pas demandé la même chose mais
est ce qui est arrivé en disant ce n'est
pas mon sens sur la fourrure parce que
je suis ménopausées en quoi la cause de
cinéma et elle servit pardonne moi
j'adore votre émission merci jugés au
plus et moi pour moi cette série ça ne
sert à rien à part à faire du buzz
en quoi se mettre nu avoir du sang sur
soi des tampons ça défend les
intermittents ça n'a juste rien à voir
pour moi d'après toutes les causes du
moment mythe ou l'inceste les en excuse
rsa corinne malderen connaissait sa vie
mais dans un arrêté est la salle non je
la connais pas et alors jeune homme et
une femme dire et qui est vraiment
impliqué le corps qui a été d'à côté
anglais qui s'était passé parce que
c'est moi elle se mêlaient elle met à
l'emblème a terminé elle se met en congé
c'est ça non mais non mais
usagers en guise de boucles d'oreilles
avec du sang sur elle elle mélange tout
et pardon en tant que téléspectateur je
trouve que le message n'est pas clair et
je trouve que c'est deux poids deux
mesures parce que demain la série vous
faites ça monte pmp toulouse va dire ah
mais c'est n'importe quoi lasser les
césars tout le monde crie au génie
attends je vais un peu je dis pas que
c'est n'importe quoi ce qu'elle a fait
qu a eu le courage de le faire
après voilà duré trois heures et demie
pendant trois heures et oui il était une
tribune politique
ouais six mois la saur ylmaz iront comme
moi et que genève un happening pour
dénoncer quelque chose peut-être que ça
aurait été moins à la cérémonie était
triste n'a pas digéré non comme a dit
michèle bernier il c'était triste
c'était une drôle d'idée de junon et
puis bon moment c'était les hommages aux
morts et les chansons de violeta biolay
avec axa s'est excusé moi oui oui moi je
vous entends pas et puis dix minutes il
ya un grand père dont je dis enfin
cinéma effectivement j'ai regardé la
cérémonie et leur bon la pire ou pas la
pire ce même pas le propos c'est
qu'effectivement entre les césar 2 2
samedi soir et bfm et ses news j'avais
la même émission tv
voilà des mots des idées des langages
des éléments de langage maison qui prend
des positions alors évidemment oui
évidemment évidemment que les
intermittents on sait à quel point ils
sont dans la merde ça fait ça fait bien
sûr des mois et des mois que les attend
bien dans mes le poids de la neige
c'est déjà le cinéma français
franchement il y adhérer une scission
entre comme l'a dit rien il ya six ans
entre le bon cinéma le cinéma bobo qu'il
faut qu'il faut aller voir et puis le
cinéma populaire déjà déjà des serpents
ça sinon c'est marc beaudet la grc a
grillé une scission mais là franchement
quand j'avais ses missions et dieu je
sais que j'aime le cinéma et que j'ai
aimé les césar les franchement il ya un
seul grand perdant excusez moi ici c'est
le sénat
alors justement regardez moi j'ai
remarqué quelque chose n'y a pas que les
téléspectateurs qui n'en pouvait plus de
cette cérémonie
il ya aussi le public regarde et qui
s'appliquent aux grecs
alors ce qui est frappant chez chaque
mot du style libre
c'est cette faculté à savoir les jeunes
assumer sa nature et j'en avais beaucoup
mais je sais ce que vous allez me dire
marina pardon je retombe dans les pièges
ah mais oui
ouais mais c'est vrai que c'était
extrêmement long maintenant c'était
attendu c'est quand c'est bien s'est
jamais long way qui ça a donné envie
d'aller au cinéma alors que la semaine
que j'adore la question et moi j'y vois
là il ya le film de de zadig dans lequel
veut sur ben voilà donc oui mais voilà
dans mes animaux sont allés voir deux
bel et bien participé
mais ce qu'on regarde et attend des
cieux et c'est plutôt vers l'étape et
ses 4 heures j'ai vraiment envie de voir
normes alors jusqu'à cette étape aussi
sur marina foïs
est-ce que c'était une vanne quand elle
a dit qu'elle n'était pas payée pour la
cérémonie
on a eu des personnes notamment à la
bonne était rémunéré pour la cérémonie
marina voilà c'est ce qu'on nous a dit
après mais hélas twitter c'est normal
les auteurs mais après l'interrogation
c'est surtout contextuellement on sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens moi j'suis pas
d'accord puisque je suis propriétaire
d'un théâtre à paris qu'il tâte de 10 ha
franchement je te le dis avec beaucoup
de sympathie des 1
franchement je n'arrive même pas à me
plaindre vis-à-vis les gens qui sont
vraiment dans une précarité à temps pour
aller au bout c'est à dire qu'il ya des
gens qui souffrent mais bien il se dit
on vit dans un pays où le régime de
l'intermittence nous permet quand on met
rapidement n'y en ait pas intermittents
non mais c'est pas le problème
c'est en tout cas les gens qui portaient
le discours samedi et notamment les gens
qui passent leur vie à te parler pardon
de te dire ça parce que tu animes une
soirée contre le racisme
le premier racisme ne mentent pas
forcément de là on pourrait le croire
le racisme il est de se dire à chaque
fois le cinéma français il est en vase
clos
combien d'arbres ou bien noir combien de
chinois de je ne sais quoi sont invités
à cette cérémonie je suis n'avoir pas
des gens mais par contre il faut un truc
qui présente le redis ce que j'ai gerald
à leur place j'aimerais qu'on vienne sur
un dossier et roselyne bachelot qui n'a
pas pu aller dans la salle
pourquoi est ce que vous savez pourquoi
bernard montiel oui mais non elle
n'avait pas droit d'aller dans la salle
tout simplement parce que c'était les
nominés qui étaient installées avec 150
personnes papus en revanche elle était
dans les coulisses où elle a rencontré
tous les arts qu'est ce qu'elle a pensé
de la soirée alors c'était de la merde
formule mieux moi je vous dirai jamais
mieux
merci bon c'est sympa pour moi oui non
je vous adore le cinéma j'étais très
triste de voir cette soirée de merde
teheran une soirée de merde en revanche
je sors du lot fanny ardant qui est
toujours sublime la survie sens
biologique major il c'est très beau il
faut quand même le dire souchon soucha
non non non mais moi je dois bio léger
doux et saïda blooded aussi le dire mais
tout le reste il aurait fait quatre ans
que vous dire voilà alors est-ce qu'il
va les voir les césar les prochaines sur
canal nous y voilà il y aura mon nez ce
n'est rien voilà qui choisiront ce qu'on
aimerait c'est quelque chose de
populaire voilà avec des artistes
populaires qui nous font rire et que ce
soit la fête là c'est la tristesse
c'était la torpeur tard donc il faut que
ça continue dans une crise j'ai des tas
de gens qui sont n'a envie de rigoler
oui on a envie de rigoler on est en
spectacle
exact est pas une sorte de machine avec
le gauchisme pour les nations unies la
raison l'a perdue qu'avec un seul rue
que vous êtes vous avez monté paupières
charnier a au départ les césars c'était
la cérémonie attendue par tous les
français depuis d'ailleurs il l'a dit
mais souvenez vous de ces moments là qui
était un moment extraordinaire là
aujourd'hui c'est du saccage depuis des
années c'est de l'entre- soit on va voir
ce qu'on pensait téléspectateurs oui à
84% non à cette motion loyer ou pas il
n'ya que la famille de marie da qui a
dit non